TATAR.
WALKING IN.
PLAYS IT ACROSS AND TO TATARY, .
HUGHES SHOOTING.
PUCK GOT THROUGH AND THEYUGHES
CREATES A LITTLE TIME AND SPACE
FORE EXPECT FROM
NICO HISCHIER ZACHA POSSIBLY BUE
RAN OUT OF REAL ESTATE A LITTLE
>> Steve: EBERLE HAS A
ND WINDS S
FOR TATAR WITH THE  ONE OF THE
DEVILS TOP LINE.
IT'S TAKEN HERE BY ZACHA AND OP
INITIALLY.
THERE'S THE PASS FROM HUGHES
GOAL OF THE SEASON.
DEVILS JUST COULDN'T BEAT THE
CLOCK AT THE END OF THE FIRST.
>> Steve: TAKEN AWAY BY HISTY GG
THE KRAKEN A POWER PLAY.
>> Steve: TARTAR LOST THE KRAKE.
I BELIEVE THE
CHICAGO.
SCHWARTZ.
THE PASS FOR GOURDE ANDOK PASS.
DEVILS HAVE USED HIS QUICKNESS
TO GET TO THOSE OLEKSIAK.
THE KRAKEN ARE ONSI NOW HERE.
AFTER THE DEVILS.
AT  AND REBOUND GOES R
AND NOW BAD ONE.
HERE'S ANDREAS JOHNSSON IN JOHN.
VESEY IN FRONT.
LOOK AT THE PUCK M
WITH NOW LINE MATES AND CHANGE.
SCORE!
WENBERG
GRAIN.
KIND OF PULLS THAT PUCK A SEE.
>> Ken: OH, BOY.T BACK.
HERE'S P.K., AND ACROSS BY A GO
JARRED McCANN WICKED WRIST SHOT
TO MAKE IT
SCREEN RIGHT HERE.
NO CHANCE FOR BERNIER.
YOU WANT T T FROM
MICHAEL McLEOD WHO SKATES ITETW
HISCHIHI